und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend gestern abend ging in berlin ein
wut brief raus an 246 abgeordnete die
eigenen leute von den chefs der cdu csu
fraktion im bundestag
sie verurteilen mit vollkommenem
unverständnis abgeordnete die bei der
vermittlung von corona schutzmasken
deals die hand aufgehalten haben sollen
wut und klartext haben gründe
geschäftemacherei bei lebenswichtigen
gütern gefährdet das was eine demokratie
in krisen stark machen soll stärker als
autoritäre regime das vertrauen der
regierten in das handeln der regierenden
da geht es also um mehr als um schuld
und sühne einiger abgeordneter mathis
feldhoff berichtet erst waren sie
umstritten gelten als wirkungslos dann
waren sie knapp und wurden zum begehrten
gut
ein umstand den auch nikolas löbel
erkannte und gegen jeden anstand für
sich nutzte mit guten china kontakten zu
einem kommunistischen volkskammer
abgeordnete zufällig masken produzent
prahlen fehlte der christdemokrat einen
deal ein der ihm 250.000 euro erwarten
geschäfte mit der note für die cdu die
derzeit auf den marktplätzen nach wlan
sucht eine echte katastrophe dem
rheinland-pfälzischen spitzenkandidaten
platz heute mittag der kragen das passt
nicht in unsere partei das ist
unanständig ich will es nicht noch
härter formulieren ich bin da wirklich
erzürnt löbel der aus mannheim kommt
zieht auch den zorn seines
heimatverbandes auf sich rücktritt
rausschmiss vieles scheint möglich wenn
er das mandat dafür eingesetzt wurde
diese diesen verkauf diese vermittlung
zu bewerkstelligen dann ist auch der
rücktritt umgehend erforderlich ist
möchte ich in aller offenheit sagen
schon der fall nüßlein vor zehn tagen
war spektakulär
660.000 euro provisionen sollen
geflossen sein
inzwischen ermittle die
staatsanwaltschaft in der
unions-fraktion schäumten vor wut in
einem brandbrief der fraktionsspitze
heißt es das beziehen von geldleistungen
für die vermittlung
medizinischer schutzausrüstung stößt auf
unser vollkommenes unverständnis es
schade dem ansehen der politik insgesamt
und ist nicht zu akzeptieren
wohl auch wenn man weitere fälle nicht
ausschließt löbel hat unterdessen seinen
deal als privat und marktgerecht
verteidigt eine eigensinnige ansicht das
problem in diesen beiden fällen ist dass
die beiden mit hohem sehr hohen beträgen
davon persönlich profitiert haben und
das erweckt den anschein dass politiker
insgesamt im käuflich sind auch der
koalitionspartner verlangt aufklärung
gerade in einer zeit in der ist so auf
vertrauen ankommt ist es gift wenn der
eindruck entsteht hier herrschen
vetternwirtschaft und raffgier dutzende
abgeordnete hatten sich mit
hilfsangeboten zu masken im letzten jahr
gemeldet ob noch mehr die hand
aufgehalten haben ist die große
unbekannte
der cdu-abgeordnete löbel hat seinen
sitz im auswärtigen ausschuss der
auslandskontakte sicher erleichtert
aufgegeben
der csu-abgeordnete nüßlein verzichtet
darauf bei der bundestagswahl im
september wieder anzutreten
ihre akten bleiben gewiss dennoch auf
wiedervorlage
es ist samstagabend viertel vor elf an
diesem einen tag heute impfen die
vereinigten staaten so viele bürger wie
deutschland in den letzten zwei wochen
da wäre es schon gut wenn wenigstens für
nächste woche versprochene schnelltests
für jedermann rasen in schwung kamen die
professionell und die zum selbermachen
die sollte es seit heute morgen zu
kaufen geben elisabeth schmidt berichtet
nudeln tomaten und ein schnelltest für
zu hause
all die lok mit maden abstrichen zu
discountpreisen doch vielerorts gibt es
erst mal nur ein paar dutzend packungen
pro filiale
beim konkurrenten lidl der ab heute
selbst erst online verkauft ist die
website zeitweise dem ansturm nicht
gewachsen
der einzelhandel kommt der
bundesregierung bei den schnelltest
zuvor die regierung unsere regierung der
es nicht schafft
die regierung hätte sicherlich er damit
anfangen sollen
gut nun ist aldi der vorreiter hoffen
wir mal dass die anderen dann daraus
lernen und dann auch das wirklich
nachziehen 5 leihen schnelltests für
knapp 25 euro
der kunde muss vorerst selbst in die
tasche greifen kostenlose schnelltests
vom bund durchgeführt von medizinischen
personal soll es flächendeckend erst ab
april geben
und das obwohl sich virus mutationen
weiter ausbreiten
forscher der tu berlin haben errechnet
wie sich die zahl der korona infektionen
durch laien und profis schnelltests
verringern diese sogar bei geöffneten
schulen und wenn sich die bevölkerung
größtenteils außer haus bewegt ohne
tests so warnen sie würde es zu einer
dritten infektionswelle kommen ließen
sich 20 prozent der menschen zweimal die
woche testen wird die infektions kurve
bereits kleiner ließen sich 40 prozent
testen käme man gegen eine dritte welle
an
ich glaube wir müssen an der einen oder
anderen stelle auf die eigene
verantwortung der leute setzen also es
wäre sicher gut wenn man sich vor jedem
privaten treffen testen lassen wurde
oder auch selber testen würde nein
schnelltests funktionieren ähnlich wie
ein schwangerschaftstest nach etwa einer
viertelstunde ist das ergebnis da
allerdings schlagen schnelltests bei
einer beginnenden infektion meist nicht
an ein allheilmittel sind sie nicht das
muss zusätzlich seien und man kann eben
bei einem negativen test jetzt nicht die
maske wegnehmen und die großmutter
umarmen
man muss auch dann noch die
hygieneregeln einhalten eine
deutschlandweite informationskampagne
was schnelltest können und was nicht sei
dringend erforderlich testkit plus
packungsbeilage sind nur ein erster
schritt
nachrichten nun von gunter weigand vor
einem rückfall in alte rollenmuster hat
bundeskanzlerin merkel gewarnt
es seien doch wieder überwiegend die
frauen die den spagat zwischen
kinderbetreuung homeschooling und dem
eigenen beruf meisterten sagte sie in
ihrem aktuellen podcast auch mit blick
auf den weltfrauentag am montag
merkel mahnte parität in allen bereichen
der gesellschaft an
in mehreren städten haben gegner der
korona maßnahmen demonstriert so kamen
in leipzig demonstranten
etwa 350 fahrzeugen zu einem autokorso
zusammen deutlich weniger als erwartet
die polizei war mit einem großaufgebot
im einsatz bei einer gegendemo unter dem
motto querdenken ausbremsen waren rund
1000 menschen unterwegs per fahrrad oder
motorrad
die usa wollen sich mit einem hilfspaket
im umfang von umgerechnet 1,6 millionen
euro gegen die korona krise stemmen
der senat stimmte nach langer debatte
den von präsident beiden vorgeschlagenen
maßnahmen zu neue jobs sollen geschaffen
millionen us-bürger mit direktzahlungen
von 1400 dollar unterstützt werden die
zustimmung des repräsentantenhauses gilt
als sicher in myanmar gehen die proteste
gegen das militärregime weiter trotz
zunehmender gewalt der sicherheitskräfte
erneut setzten polizisten und soldaten
in mehreren städten tränengas und
blendgranaten ein um die demonstranten
auseinanderzutreiben
internationale forderungen an den
weltsicherheitsrat dem militärregime
einhalt zu gebieten sind bislang
folgenlos
die begegnung zweier alter männer hat
den tag heute historisch gemacht zwei
die in kalten macht kategorien nichts zu
sagen haben sie können weder grenzen
noch toppen noch milliarden berge an
geld bewegen ihr einziger hebel sind
glaube und gottesfurcht von vielen
hundert millionen menschen
pubs franziskus reist in iraks biblische
landschaft wo bei abraham jüdischer
christlicher und muslimischer glaube
ihre gemeinsame wurzel haben sollen
christliche tradition geht 2000 jahre
zurück die schiitisch muslimische fast
1400 und in der ganzen zeit gab es noch
nie eine solche begegnung
die bilder vom entscheidenden treffen
heute sind von beeindruckender
bescheidenheit
es gibt momente die jeder % werten würde
andreas postel berichtet
wenn alles auf dieser reise symbolisch
aufgeladen ist dann sind die weißen
tauben am morgen in nadschaf ein mehr
als gewünschtes zeichen herbst
franziskus besucht in der heiligen stadt
der schiiten den großayatollah sistani
es gibt nur diese wenigen auftakt bilde
auch das sicher kein zufall dass als
privat deklarierte gespräch dauert 40
minuten eine gemeinsame erklärung wie
2009 10 mit den sunniten wird es nicht
geben
allein dass diese begegnung stattfindet
wird als kleine sensation gewertet
tag 2 der pilgerreise des papstes steht
ganz im zeichen des interreligiösen
dialogs und die erwartungen auch in der
ebene von uhr sind hoch ohne zweifel ist
dieses treffen von sehr grosser
tragweite
wir kehren zu unseren moralischen und
spirituellen wurzeln zurück die alle
menschen miteinander teilen
egal welcher religion sie angehören
die antike stadt uhr gilt laut
biblischer überlieferung als
geburtsstätte abrahams des stammvaters
von juden christen und muslimen
abraham habe in den gleichen himmel
geschaut dieselben sterne gesehen so
franziskus abraham verbinde die
gläubigen frieden erfordert weder sieger
noch besiegte sondern brüder und
schwestern sie trotz der
missverständnisse und wunden der
vergangenheit den weg vom konflikt zur
einheit gehen mit der besinnung auf den
ursprung der abrahamitischen
weltreligionen will franziskus neue
brücken bauen weil glaube ich der blick
des westens
der hat dem irak so viel angetan hat
schaut wo kommt eigentlich unsere kultur
her
die kommt aus außer europäischen kontext
eben nur was außer europas sich im
zweistromland und unsere religion seine
juden christen muslime sind nicht
denkbar ohne uhr nicht denkbar ohne den
irak das heißt war ich auch eine
kulturelle verneigung vor unseren
eigenen wurzeln
wenn alles auf dieser reise symbolisch
aufgeladen ist dann ist es natürlich
auch ein signal das franziskus die messe
in bagdad im 1
kardashian ritus zelebriert da klingen
die christlichen chorälen am abend sehr
orientalisch und harmonisch
[Musik]
jürgen erbacher hat für uns auch diese
reise des papstes begleitet guten abend
nach bagdad das war ja vom timing her
wirklich problematisch erst mal ist die
sicherheitslage im irak im moment alles
andere als gut und zweitens kam die
pandemie dazu musste dass jetzt
ausgerechnet zu diesem zeitpunkt seien
papst franziskus war am ende einfach
ungeduldig er wollte die christen hier
im land nicht länger warten lassen
papst johannes paul der zweite wollte
vor über 20 jahren schon hierher in den
irak kommen saddam hussein hat es ihm
verwehrt jetzt kamen dann krieg terror
gegen die christen dazu anfang des
jahrtausends waren es noch 1,5 millionen
jetzt sind es etwa 300 350.000
franziskus wollte nicht länger nur aus
der ferne trösten und mut zusprechen und
deshalb musste er jetzt unbedingt kommen
zum anderen ist für ihn ganz wichtig der
interreligiöse dialog vor zwei jahren
hat er mit einem der führenden
sunnitischen geistlichen eine erklärung
unterzeichnet mit einer absage an
jegliche gewalt hass und terror im namen
der religion
hier will er jetzt auch die schiiten ins
boot holen und deshalb ist er in den
irak gekommen denn hier lebt mit
großayatollah sistani einer der
führenden schiitischen geistlichen
nun war diese szene in diesen
bescheidenen privathaus heute eine fast
rührende szene diese begegnung der
beiden männer
das ist aber alles sorgfältig
abgesprochen und inszeniert wie viel
persönlichkeit kommt da überhaupt noch
rein wie viel auch annäherungen zwischen
zwei menschen gut die erklärungen die
man im anschluss bekommen hat die sind
vorbereitet von den jeweiligen städten
aber man weiß gerade von pubs franziskus
dass er in einem solch persönlichen
gespräch durchaus sein gesprächspartner
beeindrucken kann und dass da einiges
sich entwickeln kann
die beiden haben 45 minuten gesprochen
also länger als geplant von daher hatten
sie sich offensichtlich auch einiges zu
sagen
für den papst ist es einfach wichtig
gerade in den letzten jahren beim dialog
mit den religionen voranzukommen das
bringt dem auch gelegentlich kritik in
den eigenen reihen
weil wenn ein papst sagt gott liebt alle
menschen
ganz gleich welcher religion und auch
die ohne religion dann ist es gerade für
konservative katholiken eine
herausforderung und hier gibt es sicher
noch einige aufgaben hausaufgaben im
eigenen haus zu bestellen aber gerade
diese art die überzeugt bei franziskus
und das lässt dann ein solches gespräch
am ende auch noch sehr persönlich werden
und da kann einiges erwachsen was genau
das muss dann die zukunft zeigen
ein bemerkenswerter tag dankeschön nach
bagdad gute heimreise
und es gab auch am hohen himmel heute
bemerkenswert ist ziemlich weit weg auf
dem mars hat das nasa fahrzeugkorso wir
uns eine erste testfahrt erfolgreich
absolviert für die etwa sechseinhalb
meter brauchte der tonnenschwere roboter
33 minuten
die fahrt sei unglaublich gut verlaufen
so die nasa providence war mitte februar
auf dem mars gelandet und soll nach
spuren von früheren mikrobiellen leben
suchen sowie das klima des planeten
erkunden
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto lauten ohne
gewähr
1 37 29 33 35 superzahl 7 mehr auf lotto
zdf de und im zdf text und das wetter
bleibt zweigeteilt im norden wolkig und
im süden sonniger morgen kann es im
nordosten auch etwas regnen sonst gibt
es mehr sonne zwischen main und donau
ist es auch wolkenlos an der ostsee weht
ein starker westwind bei drei bis elf
grad die nächte bringen nochmal
minustemperaturen
so bleibt es auch in der nächsten woche
im norden mehr wolken und etwas regen
und im süden sonniger und alles vom
sport jetzt im sportstudio mit dunja
hayali für vergnügen dabei und bis
morgen sonntag
[Musik]